now he is no doubt one of the greatest
storytellers of our time cbs
correspondent steve hartman he's crafted
countless pieces that get to the heart
of america with his on the road segments
this time his travels took him here to
las vegas where once again heather mills
sat down with him to find out what makes
them tick
as steve hartman says everyone has a
story including him but the pandemic
offered a new look at the man who's
known for shining a spotlight on america
i'm going to start by introducing my
faculty members first of all we have my
daughter meryl she's going to help out
here
and my son emmett is our cameraman a
pandemic shaped experiment kindness 101
was steve hartman perhaps a learning
tool for everyone it was really hard you
know i do on the road and all of a
sudden i'm in my house you know it's not
the nature of the segment we did the
best we could over zoom i incorporated
my children and did some things with
them because i'm stuck at home and
they're in my office hounding me anyway
might as well put them on tv we took
stories and we sort of framed them and
used them to teach lessons on on empathy
or gratitude or honesty integrity so my
kids are now on broadcast television and
i know that they're going to be asking
for an increase in allowance because of
it what do you think everything so does
that come first dad and then journalist
yeah i try i try to do it that way but
it you know it can be stressful
but this father of three through years
of storytelling understood america's
need to come together even when
separated in a virtual world and that's
how taps across america came to fruition
we're hoping this becomes like a
national tradition
we found a guy named don britton who was
standing on his porch
every day at sunset he was playing taps
and what surprised us most on that shoot
was that when he would play
other people would come out and stand on
their balconies stand on their porches
and they would stand their hand over
heart and it was a beautiful thing and i
thought what if all of america could
feel what i was feeling in that moment
that was 2013 then the pandemic hit and
america was in need of a little
inspiration we do it at three o'clock on
memorial day which is the moment of
remembrance and take a moment just to
reflect on what the holiday is all about
steve hartman finding the good and
sharing his love of america heather
mills live local now